elle peut être rouge verte ou bleue
exubérante voire personnalisés mais
toujours avec ses courbes et ses phares
tour né en 1938 la coccinelle de
volkswagen c'est la star du week-end au
camping du château sur cher à la coke
c'est la liberté
c'est un rappel et un retour dans les
années 60 70
suivant le modèle qu'on a et c'est une
façon de laisser une façon de s'évader
faire des soirées boire un coup ou entre
amis j dans laquelle fut à côté c'était
le moyen de transport c'est une voiture
de jeunesse ils étaient déjà plus d'une
centaine dès l'ouverture du
rassemblement des férus comme nathalie
mais tu avais jamais vu des photos non
d'accord piqué par la coccinelle à l'âge
de 18 ans une passion familiale qu'elle
n'a pas hésité à se faire ancrer dans la
peau et qu'on peut avoir un
rassemblement à ans ou dans les voitures
et si le temps le permet et voilà que
c'est ça correspond à notre emploi du
temps entre hass et on vit notre passion
à fond c'est des week-ends qu'on
manquerait pas un week-end qui aurait
pourtant pu ne jamais avoir lieu en
raison du contexte sanitaire plusieurs
rassemblements ont été annulés ces
derniers mois malgré une délocalisation
forcée dans le loir et cher le club de
vierzon a tout mis en oeuvre pour
maintenir son mythique
on avait la possibilité de reporter un
autre événement qui était prévu
initialement au mois de mai là au mois
de septembre et on a sauté sur
l'occasion on tenait absolument à
proposer quelque chose à tous nos
copains qui sont là aujourd'hui
voilà quoi ça l'esprit familial de laver
le rassemblement se poursuit jusqu'à ce
dimanche 18 heures près de 300
coccinelles sont attendues sur
l'ensemble du week end